who is a postdoc with susan murphy at
harvard
he completed his phd at university of
michigan and he's been focusing on
things around
reinforcement learning for mobile health
settings so i'm very excited to hear his
talk
thanks for joining us uh thanks for the
uh introduction um
it's my great pleasure to be part of
this uh very exciting workshop i benefit
so much from attending the talks over
the past
few days so the topic i'm going to
present today is the best
policy learning in average reward markup
decision process uh
this is a joint work with jungling at
george washington university and my
advisor susan murphy
i apologize if you can hear the noise in
my background there is some
repairing work that is happening right
up above my head
uh so uh let's get started um
so this work is motivated by the mobile
health applications uh the technological
advancement
in mobile sensing allows us to not only
collect data in real time but also to
deliver the interventions anytime and
anywhere
ideally we want to use this real-time
collective information to deliver what
we call the
adjusting time adaptive interventions
that is to deliver
the right interventions to help the
users to achieve their
health goals and maintain the healthy
behavior over a longer period of time
for example to help the users to
increase their physical activity or to
reduce the stress or
even to help them to quit smoking many
mobile health interventions are
are designed for long-term use on the
other hand most of the currently
deployed interventions use expert
derived policies with
little data evidence in this talk i'll
be focusing on
on the batch setting i will present an
approach for using the pre-collected
data
to learn the treatment policies that can
optimize the long-term performance
when used in the future
so um so let's talk about the problem
set up in more
detail um so on each individual we
collect data over capital t
time points uh we use the standard
notations in reinforcement learning
uh s represents the states uh aced
action right or sometimes i call it
treatment in the context of the
mobile health are and r is the reward uh
in the mobile health the reward is
typically the health outcome measuring
the
the neurotin effectiveness of the of the
interventions are
and we are in the in the batch setting
so we cannot control how the actions are
selected um
so the election are selected by uh the
the behavioral policies are in this work
uh we do not require to have access to
the
to the behavioral policies uh also we uh
the behavioral process is allowed to uh
depends on the
entire past history arbitrarily not only
the current state uh
so we'll be focusing on the settings
where the training data consists of
an uh iid copies of the trajectory of
link
of links t
so we use the markov decision process
framework so we assume the markup
property
for the evolution of the states and we
assume the state dynamic is stationary
um so for a given policy pi we defined
the long-term average reward or the
average we worked
for sure uh in general the average
reward uh
is a function of the states uh but when
the induced markov chain is irreducible
every
average reward becomes a constant and
equal to the
uh to the expected immediate reward
under the stationary distribution and
the existence of the saturn distribution
is guaranteed by the
by the irreducibility uh these are the
the
standard results in the average we were
mdp
so um so why we are interested in using
the long-term average reward to
to evaluate a treatment policies uh
remember the goal here is to optimize
the long-term performance of the mobile
health
policies uh so the average reward
provides a high quality proxy for the
expected average reward
uh over a long period of time the reason
why this is uh we call uh we
think this is a high quality proxy is
because the arrow decreases in the order
of one over
t star as opposed to the like the usual
one over square root t
uh of course here the leading constants
will depends on
depends on the mixing time of the
induced uh policies
and we use the average reward to to
serve as a proxy for the long-term
average we
don't ever do all for a long period of
time
that's that's the motivation for using
the average reward
and um and we consider a pre a process
if we specify parametric policy class
instead of
directly estimating the unrestricted
optimal policies we use the policy class
this allows us to to kind of borrow the
domain not
knowledge to construct a policy class
for example
to choose which variable is important
for decision making and
so that we can put that in the policy
and also this can ensure the
interpretability of the learned policies
the goal here is to efficiently learn
the the optimal in-class policies using
the pre-collected data of
of an id trajectories the efficiency
here is a
it's a big consideration for this work
because the amount of the data in health
application is often quite limited
and could be expensive to to collect
to officially learn the policy we
proposed to first construct the
efficient estimator for the average
reward
of a given policy and then we performed
the positive search
by maximum by maximizing the
estimated average we were so that's the
that's the setup
um
so we will use the semi-parametric
theory to uh
to kind of inform the efficient
estimator uh where we
we treat the average reward uh as the
parameter of interest
so here's just a quick one slide review
of the of the semi-parametric statistics
uh
uh we have this notion of the
semi-parametric efficiency bound
this is essentially the asymptotic lower
bounds
on the variance of the estimator of the
brack for the parameters and
and the efficiency influence function is
is the influence function
of a regular estimator that achieved the
the
semi-parametric efficient spell uh
roughly speaking an estimator is called
regular
uh if if we can have this uh
if we can have this linear
representation here the fee is called
the influence function
kind of capturing how the arrow how each
how each data influence the arrow of the
estimator
is the standard procedure in statistics
that
we use the efficiency influence function
to construct of the efficient estimator
and this is
the approach we're going to take here
so we um so just introduce a few
notations uh we use the q
pi to denote the
denote the the relative value function
uh the state action value function
and and we use d pi to denote the
stationary distribution of the state
action pair uh
for the policy pi and we use the d d
of uh to to denote the the average
distribution of the state action pair
uh averaging over t decision times in
the data set uh
remember the data set is collected under
the behavioral policies uh
so each of this little t uh uh the dd
is the the marginal density for the
state action pair
at that specific time point and we take
the take the average um
uh under uh some regularity conditions
uh we can derive the efficiency
influence function for the average
reward
given given the given data set of an id
trajectories
this involves the ratio of the two
density
and also the relative value functions
are
yeah the term in the parenthesis is the
the td arrow so that
so the efficiency influence function is
essentially like the average of the
weighted
uh weighted uh td error
at the true value right
um
so for some for simplicity i will use
the u pi to denote the like
this difference of the value of the
relative value function at two different
states
and we use the omega to denote the
density ratio
with these two notations the efficient
infrared function can be written
as this simplified form suppose we are
given some estimator for this two
nuisance function u pi and omega pi
we can then estimate the average reward
by solving the plugging estimating
equations
uh since the average reward is a number
we can find uh we can find the
expression for the estimator
explicitly as shown in this slide
here p n is the empirical average over
introductories in the data set
the standard notations are here i use
the terminology nuisance functions to to
call this u pi
and make a pi because the parameter of
interest
in this work is the is the average
reward so we treat this u pi
and omega pi as some new sense functions
uh
some notion functions um so a nice
property of this plug-in estimator is
the
is the so-called doubly robustness ah as
long as we can consistently estimate one
of the nuisance functions uh the plugin
estimator
is guaranteed to be uh guaranteed to be
consistent
mean a quick question so in general
estimating w is hard and
there's been sort of like the dual dice
and other nice work to do that will you
talk about particular choices for
estimating
um yes i will be i'll be talking about
that right
this is coming up in the next few slides
um yes just um yes uh so i will be
talking about how to estimate these
nuisance functions uh just to give you a
and a quick overview of that um
uh so in this work we will uh
consider uh using a flexible number
metric estimator for both of the
nuisance functions u pi and omega pi
uh as you as we will see in the next
couple of slides uh both estimators
involves solving a coupled or
a nested optimization problem but due to
the
time constraint i will only be talking
about like the high level ideas but
and go rather fast but but feel free to
look at the archive
if you're interested in more details so
uh so let's start with
how we estimate the value functions are
so the estimation of this value function
is based on uh
solving the development equations for
policy evaluation
the solution of the bellman equations is
unique up to a constant for q pi
uh but for the purpose of estimating u
pi which is
like the difference of the relative
value functions we only need to learn
a specific version of the of the of the
true value functions
um right um so
so for given eta and q uh we project
uh just the uh
we project the so-called development
arrow uh to a non-parametric function
class
g and we and we will denote the
projection by by this g
hat uh and it depends on the policy pi
we are we are evaluating
and also depends on the data and q uh
uh since the bellman arrow is zero at
the at the true average reward and the
and the value functions are we will
minimize
like the square of the projective
element error over all possible
eta and q in the function class f
to obtain the estimator to obtain the
estimator for q pi
uh notice here um we are
directly projecting the belmont arrow to
a space g as opposed to
like estimating the the bellman operator
which is more
uh uh which which is
often used in the literature uh the
reason why we
project a development error instead of
the belmont operator thermal operator is
the left-hand side of this
is this condition expectation uh the
reason why we did that is because we
uh we we use that to relax the
assumption that
the bellman operator has to be closed
under under the under the function class
g for all possible functions in f
uh which we will see uh later uh as we
talk about uh
the theoretical results uh here i
uh another things to notice is that uh
here i used f
and g uh for two function classes uh in
practice these two function cuts can be
can can be chosen to be the same uh up
to but up to accounts
up to a constant shift but to emphasize
like the two different rules of the f
and g
in in the estimation procedure in
particular f is used to
approximate the value function and g is
used to approximate the bellman arrow
uh we will use two different we use two
different notations
just to clarify that uh different roles
uh so this is uh this is the
estimation for the value function now
i'm gonna talk about how we
how we can estimate the density ratio in
a similar fashion
uh so we first uh we introduced a scaled
version of the density ratio
distance we call it the e pi and this
scaling ensures that the expectation of
the e pi under the stationary
distribution is
one uh similar to the to the value uh
uh relative value function we can define
this little q pi
uh essentially this is you can think of
it as an mdp
but not the reward is changed to 1 minus
this e pi
because of the scouting this one minus e
pi dot the average reward
for average word for this new mvp is
equal to 0
so that this value function is well
defined
right so uh it can be shown that this
little cube pi
can be characterized as a minimizer of
some objective functions similar to the
similar to the square of the bellman
arrow uh here the
this delta pi is a function of the
current state
uh current action the next states and
also depends on the queue
that we are we we are evaluating this is
a
this is similar to a td arrow uh this is
similar to the td error
right so and we can use this uh
characterization to
to motivate the estimator uh the similar
to the case of value function are
we minimizing we uh we use this g hat
uh n pi of q to denote the
uh the estimator for the conditional
expectation of delta pi
given given the q and we're minimizing
the
the square of this arrow uh plus some uh
penalty term
uh right as emma just mentioned there is
uh growing literature about how
how about the estimation of the density
ratio uh those
dice uh estimator uh most of those met
most of the methods are uh are the are
so called the mini max based methods uh
which is quite different to the methods
presented here uh as we are
kind of solving a couple optimization
the reason why it's a couple is because
the objective function here
involves involves involves solving
another optimization problem
the advantage of this coupling estimator
over the existing minimax methods is
that
it's easier to control the the
overfitting uh
by using this regularization term and uh
and it also allows us to directly derive
the error bond for the density ratio
estimation
uh when when the function space are
reproducing kernel hubus space well we
can find we can find the closed form
solutions to the estimator
similar to the minimax estimator
but here we have to pay additional
computational price uh the computational
capacity for this map for this coupling
methods is
higher as we have to invert the kernel
matrix well which
which is not which we don't have to
invert any kind of edges in the minimax
base methods right
um so so now i'm gonna uh
go over uh briefly talk about some of
the key assumptions
uh for the for our theoretical results
uh
so our first set of assumption is on the
on the policy class uh
we will use this p to denote the uh the
dimensions
of of the parameters in the policy class
uh we'll assume
uh for every policy in the class uh the
induced markov chain is
is irreducible so that the average
reward becomes a constant
we also assume the the parameter space
is compact and with a finite
diameter the most important assumption
is that
we assume the liches conditions on the
policy class uh
this lipschitz conditions is used to uh
to control the size of the class uh of
the relative value function
it for all for all the policies in the
class and also to control the size of
the
all of the density ratio in the class
right uh the second set of assumption is
for the estimation of the
of the relative uh value functions are
we use this f
uh we use this norm without any
subscript
to denote the like the average square
norm across the t distribution times
uh uh here the expectation is taken with
respect to the
to the to the to the distribution
collected under the behavioral policies
we use this e pi
to denote the development error for a
given eta and q
and we use this g pi star to denote the
the projection of the
of the belmont error on on the space g
so we we the first assumption is that
the
the the true relative value function is
correctly specified
and we also need to assume that the zero
function uh is in the space of g
uh our second assumption is is
essentially on the complexity of the
function class g
uh uh by restricting the eta and q such
that the belmont
arrow has norm one uh we assume that the
infimum
of the norm of the projected belmont
arrow uh is greater than zero um
in the case of uh in the case where the
function class are all linear function
class
uh this is again to kind of assume the
smallest eigenvalue
uh is is positive um
we do not need to assume that uh all of
the bellman arrow is correctly specif
is correctly modeled by g instead we
only need to assume that the space of g
is just rich enough to ensure that this
infimum or this smallest
smallest eigenvalue is should be
positive
yes and we also make a similar
assumption on uh for as for the density
ratio estimations are
right uh we also have this projection uh
to denote the
uh on on g2 uh and
uh and we also need to assume that this
little q pi
uh is is currently specified by the
function class
f um here remember the e pi is the scale
version
is a scale version of the density ratio
so instead of assuming
that the zero function is in the class
of in is in the class of g uh in the
value of
in the case of value function estimation
here we we need to assume that this
scale ratio uh is correctly marked it's
currently
specified by g and we also make a
similar uh eigenvalue
type assumptions on the for the capacity
of g
um uh our last our last
assumption is on the on the function
complexity uh
this is the classical entropy conditions
on the two non-parametric function class
and alpha is a constant between 0 and 1.
for some for simplicity we use we kind
of use a common alpha
for both function classes the larger
value of the alpha
the more complex of the function class
is
right so with this uh
and so now we can uh now i'm going to
talk about
the the regret bound uh here
uh the k is uh it's arbitrary integer uh
uh under some additional regularity
conditions uh
if we can chose the tuning parameter
approp appropriately
uh the regret uh that is the the
difference between the the optimal
average we were in the policy class and
the average reward
of the estimated policies uh can be
bounded
up to a constant uh by the square root
p over n p ah and plus the p times
times the n to the power of uh negative
beta k
here p is the uh is the size of the
policy class
and the alpha beta k is given uh
is given here um uh the alpha is the
is the concept between zero and one in
the matrix entropy conditions are
we see that uh beta k uh uh is a
uh converges to uh one over one plus
alpha
as k goes to infinity uh k is uh
k the constant case uh is not used in
the algorithm or
used in the in the estimation this is
only this is only using the proof
uh
uh by choosing as long as as long as k
is greater than
then three uh this beta k is going to be
uh
strictly uh larger than one half so
so ignoring the dependence of p that we
graphed is essentially one over square
root
n um
so the key to the proof is the is this
doubly robustness structure
this is used to control the the
estimation error of the average reward
due to not knowing the two nuisance two
nuisance functions
and at the uniform error bounds for the
two policy dependent nuisance function
estimator
uh even though like uh that
we see a similar structure uh for the
two
uh newton function estimator it turns
out that
it is technically more involved to bound
the arrow for the density ratio
the reason is quite subtle but at a high
level it is because we no longer have
the
zero bellman arrow at the true functions
uh
to get to get around this we come up
with a iterative procedure
uh and that is exactly the reason why we
have this k
showing up in the regret bound and this
is only for the
for the purpose of the proof uh another
thing to
just interrupt this i think there's a
question on there um which is uh
on slide 14 is there an upper bound on
the value function
or in general do you assume the value
functions are bounded yes yes yes
yes yes this is part of the
regularity conditions right thanks and
also can you remind me what alpha is
again
alpha is in the uh is in the matrix
entropy conditions
here measuring the complexity of the two
function classes
right
you don't get anything in terms of the
rates of convergence of how many samples
are needed
to realize like like what the approach
what the
um what the error is in estimating the
nuisance parameters that doesn't appear
in your final
uh yes this is part of the part of the
proof but i i didn't show it here
yes we do have a explicit bound for for
both of the uh nuisance function
estimator
but those browns don't appear in in the
theorem like
all right like the rates those rates or
or do you just assume a certain rate of
convergence um
oh we would actually prove the rate uh
for two for
both of the nuisance function estimator
under under these assumptions
okay all right thank you right
um yes another thing to notice here is
that here i'm kind of focusing on the
dependence of the n
which is the the number of the
trajectory uh in the in the data
uh obviously the the leading constant
will also depends on the
the the links uh that the time point
total time point
capital t r so under additional
assumption on the mixing property we can
get the similar bound in terms of the
total number of the transition samples
uh instead of just the n here
right i'm sorry one other quick question
which is chubbo is wondering how large
is c
as a function of k so
uh for as k goes to infinity this
constant
unfortunately goes to infinity uh but
but the exact order
is some exponential is exponential
like 2 to the power of k something
something like this
you know for anybody if that didn't
clarify your question feel free to just
put it in the chat
or in the q a again and i can always um
get you to answer live or just put in if
you'd like beta
if you'd like to answer ask it in person
thanks
all right so we have four more minutes
or so oh okay
okay um and we can
and sorry one other question by gabor
which is um what is the intuition
behind limiting your function class to
be donskar um aka that alpha is less
than one
oh i i can't see the question oh yeah
the question
from um or here i um
the the question from gabor um was
what is the interesting behind limiting
your function class to be domsker um
alpha being less than one are you making
that assumption here
right right yes yes essentially this is
like a downside type
uh assumptions for the function class
which is
somewhat limiting um so do you think
that's generally realized
reasonable for the types of domains you
look at or is it sort of future work to
extend it
this is kind of like a pretty standard
assumptions for the non-parametric
estimate
but but i believe that uh there there is
some recent work that extends this kind
of results
in the in the supervised learning
literature
and i think it can be extended to to to
the setting we consider here as well
yeah well why not when we let you finish
then we can ask additional questions
thanks everybody for your questions
right uh and we can also show the
estimator of the average we were
estimates are
kind of semi-parameter efficient under
the same kind of set of
conditions uh here the asymptotic
efficiency is in terms of the
number of id trajectories um so in other
words
for any finitely number of policies
asymptotic covariance which is the
semi-parametric feature spell um
right and we also have some uh some
numerical
example just to demonstrate uh
demonstrate the the estimation and how
and because this estimator evolved um
quite some tuning parameters so this
numerical example is just to show
uh we have a method to select the tuning
parameters based on
kind of like the cross-validation and
this simulation is just to
kind of demonstrate that the valuability
of that uh
tuning parameter selection right uh
um so uh just a quick summary of this
work uh we developed the data efficient
estimator to estimate the policy that
optimized long-term average reward and
we
are able to establish the regret
guarantee uh
um so i think i would i will take the
questions here
um
okay thank you very much for the nice
talk um uh
one of the additional questions that
just popped up was um could you clarify
a little bit the
the difference between restricting the
function class and projection to a
function class
uh like let me let me stop
hearing oh so i can see the the words uh
which um so one of the attendees asked
what is the could you clarify the
difference between
restricting the function class and
projection to a function class
um restricting to a function class are
basically just means that uh
we we we restrict the restrict all of
the functions in the class to have
like equal to zero at us at the
particular state in actions
that's what i mean by restricting a
function class
uh projection to a function class
uh uh
is we we we do that uh
l2 projections uh maybe um
i didn't understand the question
um i don't know who it was but maybe
they can uh because it was an anonymous
question but maybe if they have further
questions they can ask
um you know that i wanted to maybe uh
just before we wrap up here
i know i wanted to build on gabber's
question a little bit more it does seem
like there's been some
recent work looking at sort of the um
from the econometrics community and
and others looking at sort of um
allowing more general function classes
in particular to allow sort of deep
neural networks um
uh to be able to provide similar
guarantees um
one of the challenges that i think of um
we've done some related work just in the
sort of optimal stopping setting
for off policy evaluation is that we do
generally have to make some assumptions
about sort of convergence
both convergence rates and sort of
asymptotic consistency of the function
classes
and to me that's very hard to know for a
lot of real domains um like
you know it's uh particularly if we
choose a you know a two-layer deep
neural network how do we know whether or
not that really has um zero bias
asymptotically
so i was curious whether or not you
think there are particular techniques
that are used to tackle that um from
kind of a statistical perspective or you
if you think that's sort of a similar
question that's wrestled with in that
community
i'm not i'm not quite familiar with this
uh with this area to be honest
or i guess i mean i guess maybe at a
more high level my question is um
these type of sort of nuisance these
type of estimators tend to assume that
we have rates on the nuisance parameters
and that they are asymptotically
consistent
and i think for a lot of the common
function approximators we tend to
use right now in machine learning that
will not always be true you know a
two-layer neural network may or may not
be able to capture
q or w um and so i was curious whether
that's something
that is an equal concern in statistics
or whether that
and there's standard techniques for
handling that like changing the function
class is amount of data so you can
always
ensure asymptotic consistency or whether
that's
not so big of a concern for some other
reasons that i'm not aware of
i remember there there is some uh there
is some research about
about this about this exactly same issue
where if you have some bias uh in the
nuisance functions
and you cannot guarantee you have the
square root n uh
convergence rate but um well i'm not
very familiar with with the results
yeah but i do like but i can share with
you um
some some with some papers on on this
problem
great well um uh we should wrap up now
um
and move on to the next feature um but
uh trouble wanted maybe you could see
the q a now trouble
um also had maybe you guys can follow up
um over the chat messages but had some
questions about the guarantees for the
cv procedure
and someone else wondered about
non-asymptotic results um
so thank you so much for the talk and
i'm excited for the next speaker who
sean will introduce